Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Buonasera.
Quando mi hanno detto che avrei dovuto fare la prima talk
sono andato in crisi.
Allora mi sono detto va bene, sono in tema.
Allora mi son chiesto, dovrò iniziare a parlare di crisi.
Mi sono fatto una domanda: ma la crisi è il problema
o esiste un problema che ha generato la crisi?
Crisi è una parola che deriva dal greco.
La crisi è un momento tra uno stato di fatto e un altro stato di fatto.
È il momento di cambiamento.
Quindi la crisi non è una maledizione, la crisi è un'occasione!
Ed è l'occasione per incontrarsi
e capire qual è questo problema che ci accomuna tutti.
Ma come facciamo noi, in uno stato di crisi, a incontrarci,
quando questo stato di crisi ci allontana l'uno dall'altro?
Secondo i greci, la creatività coincide con l'atto di creare la poesia,
quindi creare uguale poetare
e la poesia, in tutte le sue declinazioni, è il teatro,
quindi canto, musica, danza.
E non è un caso che siano stati i greci
a inventare il teatro come evento sociale:
durante le rappresentazioni si parlava di etica, si parlava di morale,
si parlava del futuro della polis.
Quindi abbiamo questi due elementi:
da un lato la crisi come occasione di incontro,
dall'altro abbiamo il teatro come evento sociale.
Secondo il matematico Henri Poincaré,
la creatività è unire gli elementi già esistenti
con connessioni nuove che siano utili.
Ora l'utilità di parlare di questi problemi è indiscussa,
l'unica cosa che dobbiamo fare noi, adesso, è unire questi due elementi.
Ma per unire questi due elementi è necessario creare un luogo,
poiché queste nuove connessioni sono molto delicate.
Evento sociale, teatrale da un lato, confronto dall'altro.
Tutti i nostri respiri e tutto il nostro lavoro
è dedito a creare questi luoghi.
Il nostro motto è "Dare luogo",
e il primo luogo che noi abbiamo deciso di trasformare
è stato il luogo a noi più intimo, cioè il luogo
dove noi ci poniamo le domande quotidianamente.
Abbiamo invitato il pubblico
a partecipare in maniera attiva ai processi creativi
e abbiamo creato AltofrAgile, una rassegna di processi creativi.
Il pubblico è invitato a partecipare in maniera attiva,
seguendo un processo creativo
dal suo nascere fino alla sua fine e alla fine di ogni tappa
il pubblico lasciava una domanda,
glielo abbiamo chiesto noi, una domanda tematica,
sulla quale domanda poi lavoravano gli attori.
Così il pubblico ha potuto partecipare in maniera realmente attiva
e lo spazio della riflessione si è esteso dentro e fuori dalla scena.
Per fare la promozione di AltofrAgile noi siamo andati in strada,
abbiamo lasciato le nostre scatole AltofrAgile in tutta la città,
abbiamo chiesto alle persone di diventare i nostri promoter
e abbiamo capito una cosa: che le persone hanno voglia di partecipare,
desiderano partecipare. E allora ci siamo spinti oltre.
Abbiamo detto: "un altro luogo noi dobbiamo chiedere alle persone,
il loro luogo più intimo." E allora abbiamo bussato a casa delle persone:
abbiamo chiesto alle persone di darci i loro salotti,
le loro terrazze, le cucine,
i bagni e abbiamo creato un festival, lo abbiamo chiamato AltoFest,
un festival di arti performative per la riqualificazione umana e urbana.
Abbiamo chiesto alle persone, ai donatori di spazi,
di lasciare che degli artisti abitassero quei luoghi
e poi gli abbiamo chiesto
di ospitare anche il pubblico e così bagni, garage, terrazze
si sono trasformati in luoghi di incontro.
Alla fine di ogni giornata gli artisti, il pubblico e i donatori di spazi
si sono incontrati nell'AltoFest che facevamo
e hanno parlato dell'evento sociale
nel quale tutti avevano partecipato insieme.
Ma concludo parlando di un altro luogo, perché parlare della crisi,
sapere che c'è un problema, sapere che è condiviso non basta.
Aprire gli spazi, aprire i luoghi non basta.
C'è un altro luogo che ognuno di noi può trasformare.
Questo luogo risiede nella capacità di vedere il bello nelle cose,
di vedere la poesia anche dove essa è nascosta. E questa cosa qui
la rimpariamo ogni giorno, quando lavoriamo con i matti
del manicomio criminale di Aversa. E noi lì capiamo ogni giorno
che questi uomini, che si portano addosso i solchi della detenzione,
i solchi della contenzione farmacologica,
questi uomini sono capaci di ritrovare dentro di loro
un luogo in cui risiede la poesia, come la poesia risiede in ognuno di noi.
E allora bisogna cambiare sguardo,
bisogna lasciarsi attraversare dagli altri,
bisogna lasciare che il nostro portato attraversi gli altri.
Facciamoci luogo.
Grazie (Applausi).